the Joe Rogan experience yes so I'm a we
worked hard on it man is it's one just
because of the situation with the false
arrest it's uh is really super personal
because I kind of had to keep living
that story every time I told it and then
live it in the edit and it's uh was just
a funny situation - you're drunk and
this guy is arresting you for going back
into a bar I didn't so it wasn't that
bar I hadn't been in that bar he went to
a different I went to the bar after we
spoke I went into the bar but he was
still he was upset about what I said so
he follows me into the bar but then you
know they made they cut it on their body
cam footage they cut it made me look he
really left his post and follow me to be
on [ __ ] so yeah we probably see one
up getting fired I don't know I don't
think I think he's still on the force
for now
yeah that's there's a lot of sort of
emotion and emotion a lot of ego based
policing on on the super petty side you
know where there's obviously that you
know the issues on the extreme with the
killings that was a terrible but then
there's a lot of unfuck that are ruining
lives with patty arrests yeah somebody
gotta go they gotta miss work or
something or some some do you don't
folks get mad cuz they I looked at the
wrong way you know and then people I go
to so it's a lot of you cops should be
able to handle somebody talking a little
shits at I'm drunk you'll cop in Miami
usually be used to my mother talk a
little drunk [ __ ] to you without you
putting the cuffs on and if you can't
you shouldn't be a cop said you're
supposed to be better than us
yes god this is less of you you should
be better than us you should have the
mental fortitude in that like freak out
because some I said some [ __ ] you don't
like and you have extreme
responsibilities you have a gun on your
hip in front of everybody okay it's not
like whether or not I don't know you
have a gun you might have a gun
we have a gun it's right there and
you're allowed to shoot people you're
allowed to it's part of your job
they're trained to shoot people it's
part of your job you have to be elevated
you have to be above normal discourse
you have to be able to handle all kinds
of [ __ ] and the reality is that's not
the case with most people that are
police officers yeah man
even that cop I was I was walking away
from him
mm-hmm but I was just talking out of
[ __ ] because he just followed me into a
bar and so I'm walking away and so that
[ __ ] was really you know I I say is
absolutely instigated that situation but
it wasn't an arrest of one thing and the
cost I had to pay for that is is pretty
hot as far as this you know my public
[ __ ] on there just for a drunk night
just photographer [ __ ] I'm on TMZ I lost
some corporate gig because of that cuz
they just saw it and then oh you got
arrested I his wife the gig it was a
decent man you know it was a it was a
hockey Hannibal type of gig in that race
so it was uh it was it was a rough it
was a rough little time and after that
so that to finally kind of get the peace
out get the SPECIAL out even just
putting it out Friday like a huge weight
like none of the other specials because
it was the other special was kind of
done on a two-year clock too and they
were kind of and this one filmed it
twice out of pocket it's a super as so
many other elements that made it really
heavy and that's yeah had to close with
and that's why through a covert party
I'm sorry I'm sorry about the party I
just I just needed to blow off some
steam and those mushrooms to let you
know if it's [ __ ] up - oh man they
will let you know it they'll drag you
they would drag you to the darkest part
of your imagination yeah man Oh set and
setting is that's why they say silent
darkness is the way to
said as said in a party yeah mushrooms
thinking you killed everybody
I think you made some funerals you
looking at people vibing out this is
always this is me
[Applause]